j'ai parfois beaucoup de difficultés à
marcher
et je ne peux pas toujours utiliser mes
cordes vocales pour chanter comme je le
souhaiterais
imaginez-vous Céline Dion qui elle
chante comme elle chante qui bouge comme
elle bouge sur une scène et qui annonce
ce matin des annulations de spectacle ce
qui était prévu au printemps ça va aller
à l'année 2024 cet été tout est annulé
elle a expliqué un peu de quoi il
souffrait le syndrome de la personne
raide voilà ça fait déjà à peu près deux
ans qu'elle doit reporter annuler des
spectacles en raison de problèmes de
santé et là est-ce que nous apprend dans
une vidéo qu'elle a publié sur Instagram
plutôt ce matin c'est que la récemment
été diagnostiquée avec un trouble
neurologique le syndrome de la personne
raide et si vous ne savez pas ce que
c'est c'est tout à fait normal c'est un
trouble très rare qui affecte une
personne sur un million d'ailleurs il y
a pas encore de remède qui a été trouvé
pour ce syndrome là seulement des
médicaments pour soulager les symptômes
maintenant en quoi ça consiste
exactement je vous laisse écouter la
docteur la neurologue madame Gagnon
c'est un problème au niveau de la
réponse musculaire
qui vient du système nerveux central
la cause la plus fréquente et la
présence d'anticorps des anticorps qui
vont s'attaquer à une enzyme qui
elle-même va s'attaquer à un
eurotransmetteur qui vont faire en sorte
que les muscles ont la difficulté à se
détendre
et vous savez où est-ce qu'il y a des
muscles dans le corps entre autres dans
les cordes vocales alors voilà pourquoi
ça peut l'empêcher de chanter en plus de
l'empêcher de te marcher ça cause de
nombreux symptômes d'ailleurs je vous en
homme les principales on parle de
spasmes musculaire qui peuvent aller
jusqu'à provoquer des chutes on parle
aussi d'une raideur musculaire
progressif progressive oui ça touche
d'abord le tronc l'abdomen mais c'est un
syndrome qui est progressif donc ensuite
ça peut toucher tout le corps et
provoquer vraiment une raideur
généralisée une démarche raide également
ça peut aussi causer une tendance à
sursauter parce que les stimuli
entourant la personne comme des bruits
ça peut causer ça se passe mais là et
finalement ça peut même mener à de
l'agoraphobie alors voilà pour ce
syndrome qui sera certainement très
gouglé aujourd'hui parce qu'il y a peu
de gens qui en entendu parler en
attendant ben oui conséquence Céline
Dion doit encore une fois reporter ces
spectacles ceux du printemps et ceux qui
sont prévus pour l'été 2023 carrément
annulé pour l'instant tout ça c'est dans
le cadre de sa tournée courage qui avait
commencé en 2019 je vais terminer quand
même sur une note d'espoir elle a dit
elle-même garder espoir pour suivre ce
combat et être bien entouré non
seulement d'une équipe médicale mais
aussi de ses fils bon très bien merci je
vous en prie
on ne sait pas encore tout de cette
maladie rare
mais on sait maintenant que c'est la
cause d'espace musculaire dont je
souffle j'ai parfois beaucoup de
difficultés à marcher
et je ne peux pas toujours utiliser mes
cordes vocales pour chanter comme je le
souhaiterais
comprenez que c'est toute nouvelle
qu'elle nous annonce Céline Dion ici qui
est atteinte d'une maladie neurologique
rare ça l'oblige à mettre sur pause
d'ailleurs à repousser toute une série
de concerts dans
la série dans le cadre de courage
c'était le nom de cette série là alors
qu'est-ce que c'est que ce syndrome de
la personne raide le docteur Sophie
gagnant neurologue au centre intégré de
santé des services sociaux de l'outawa
est là pour nous en parler bonjour
Docteur Gagnon merci d'être là parce que
vous comprendrez ma surprise quand j'ai
lu cette nouvelle là ce matin et comment
elle a été accueillie reçu par tout le
monde on s'est dit qu'est-ce que c'est
que ça que le syndrome de la personne
raide
oui en effet c'est comme le dit c'est
bien Céline c'est une maladie qui est
rare on parle d'environ une à deux
personnes sur un million qui en souffre
on parle d'un syndrome c'est à dire que
c'est un ensemble de signes et symptômes
mais non pas une maladie comme telle
avec une cause et une évolution tout à
fait prévisible
ce dont on parle en fait c'est un
problème au niveau de la réponse
musculaire
qui vient du système nerveux central
la cause la plus fréquente et la
présence d'anticorps des anticorps qui
vont s'attaquer à une enzyme qui
elle-même va s'attaquer à un autre
transmetteur qui va faire en sorte que
les muscles ont la difficulté à se
détendre alors ça va causer de la Réda
ça va de la rigidité ça va causer des
spasmes qui peuvent être exacerbées par
des émotions des stress des bruits etc
bon on va reconnaître on s'en occupe
pour tout le monde à la maison comprenne
vous avez pas le dossier de Madame Dion
on peut pas en parler publiquement comme
ça là c'est juste de parler de la
maladie mais quand on comprend quand
même elle dit que ça peut ça peut
affecter les cordes vocales aussi donc
même si elle voulait chanter juste
assise il se pourrait que ce que ce
syndrome là fait ses cordes vocales
les cordes vocales sont activées par des
muscles alors partout où il y a des
muscles on est susceptibles d'avoir des
problèmes de de se passe ou de rigidité
en effet donc c'est tout à fait
vraisemblable oui bon qui sont les plus
touchés par ceux qui peut être sujet à
ça le plus propice là
ok j'y reviens on est quand même dans
des maladies qui sont ou d'un syndrome
qui est rare
les groupes d'âge les plus atteints sont
estimés entre 20 et 50 ans ça peut
toujours dépasser d'un côté ou de
l'autre les femmes sont environ deux à
trois fois plus atteintes que les hommes
on parle d'une maladie du système
immunitaire alors parfois il peut y
avoir une association avec d'autres
maladies du système immunitaire comme le
diabète militus de type 1 le vitiligo
des thyroïdes dit tout l'anémie
pernicieuse sont des maladies qui vont
activer le système immunitaire et
peuvent mettre un risque il y a une
association aussi beaucoup plus rare et
d'environ 1% des patients atteints du
syndrome de la personne reine peuvent
avoir ce qu'on appelle un syndrome
paranéopathique c'est-à-dire qu'ils ont
dans leur système immunitaire quelque
chose qui lutte contre un cancer et ce
quelque chose là se trompe de cible et
s'attaque au contrôle de de
détente musculaire
est-ce ce qui existe est-ce que là
est-ce qu'on peut guérir cette syndrome
ou est-ce qu'on peut juste le traiter la
léger
oui on peut le soulager
les traitements de base sont des
traitements qui vont favoriser une
détente musculaire le premier c'est le
diazépam qui est une benzodiacépine
c'est tellement important en fait c'est
presque un critère diagnostic pour
savoir qu'on a affaire au syndrome de la
personne red certains personnes vont
être certains patients vont être
réfractaires à ça alors on peut aller
avec d'autres médicaments qui vont
détendre les muscles comme le 29ème dans
certains cas ça va pas fonctionner non
plus une option peut-être d'aller
moduler le système immunitaire en
offrant par exemple des immunoglobulines
qui sont des anticorps sains qui
qu'on injecte et qui viennent de gens
qui ont donné du sang là à la banque de
sang et qui eux vont remplacer les
anticorps malades du patient
on peut aussi parfois faire des
placements ferraille c'est-à-dire aller
filtrer les mauvaises anticorps pour que
il y ait moins d'attaques qui se fasse
au niveau des muscles ce sont des
traitements qui doivent être répétés une
fois leur
un certain temps passé les faits n'est
plus là et ça doit malheureusement être
répété si ça ça fonctionne pas il y a
aussi moyen de donner de la
chimiothérapie avec du riz Tucson qui va
aller baisser si vous voulez
la capacité au système immunitaire de
s'attaquer encore une forme mais dans
tous les cas ce sont des traitements qui
vont soit soulager les symptômes
minimiser les attaques du système
immunitaire pour une période définie
mais qui vont pas guérir et mettre un
terme à ce problème là on s'attend à un
problème qui soit normalement progressif
progressif à quelle vitesse ça c'est
vraiment difficile à dire et ça dépend
des formes de
du syndrome
on en sait ce matin grâce à vous le
beaucoup plus même s'il y a beaucoup de
détails de spécificité tout ça mais au
moins on va comprendre un peu pour
l'allure de la journée qu'est-ce qu'on
va entendre et qu'est-ce qu'on va nous
en dire ce qu'on nous en dit davantage
on comprend bien merci beaucoup docteur
Gagnot de ces explications ce matin à la
prochaine
au revoir pour voir nos émissions en
entier rendez-vous sur la chaîne ici RDI